hi guys welcome to today's session by
simply learn
today we are going to discuss a very
exciting topic on devops
without further delay let's go ahead and
start with this session on top 10
reasons to learn devops
also before i begin please do hit the
bell icon and subscribe to our channel
to never miss an update
so today we will be talking about one of
the booming technologies used which is
devops
we will first look into what is devops
then we are going to dive deep and
understand the top 10 reasons why you
should learn devops
so what is devops devops is a
collaboration between the development
and operation teams which enables
continuous delivery of applications
and services to our end users before
devops there was a lot of communication
gap between the development and
operation teams
the code that used to work fine on the
development side would create a lot of
errors on the operation side
this in fact led to a lot of issues the
biggest issue was the delay in project
delivery
the solution to this was devops in
devops the operation and development
engineers participate together in the
entire lifecycle from the design
through the development process to the
delivery of the software to the end
users it enhances the process
to deliver the software faster and a
software of high quality
if there is any bug or error it is fixed
at the right time
rather than dragging it to the last
phase let's now look into the 10 reasons
why you should learn devops
so at number 10 we have technical
cultural and business benefits of devops
let me explain each benefit one by one
so first we have the technical benefits
continuous software delivery is the most
important process
of delivering the software in smaller
increments to ensure that the software
can be released at any time
with this approach of devops the team
will always be ready on delivering
anytime
it has the benefit of having less
complex problems to fix the code is
tested at every stage and both the
development and operation teams
make sure that the complexity is reduced
to a great extent
devops also has the benefit of faster
and easier resolution to every problem
if any bug or error is found at an
earlier stage it is fixed
and then moved on to the next stage
hence this way at the final stage
there will be zero or minimum number of
bugs moving forward
let's look into the cultural benefits of
devops the workload is divided equally
between all the employees
so no individual is under the pressure
to code test
debug an entire software this results in
a team that is happy and more productive
since devops is a collaboration between
the development and operation teams
if any issue arises on one side the team
is always ready to help
and the employees are engaged to make
sure that the software is as the end
user requires
and hence is delivered at the set date
devops helps in increasing the
professional development opportunities
finally let's look into the business
benefits of devops
the basic principles of devops that is
automation
continuous delivery and quick feedback
cycle aim to make the software
development process faster
and more efficient being an extended
version of agile methodology
devops ensures that the complete
software development lifecycle
goes smoothly by promoting collaboration
between the teams
devops offers continuous feedback so
that the errors are fixed in time and
the releases are done faster
these days the development teams need to
break down the inter-departmental
constraints and collaborate
as well as communicate in a dynamic
round-the-clock environment
devops gives a way to improve the
business agility by providing an
environment of mutual collaboration
communication and integration across the
various teams in an it organization
all the team members are responsible for
meeting the quality and timeline of the
software deliverables
with devops organizations can improve
the deployment frequency
recovery rates and hence result in a
lower failure rate
with every new release it is possible to
ensure the reliability and stability of
an application
when applications perform flawlessly in
the market organizations reap the
benefits of greater customer
satisfaction
at the ninth position we have work with
good developers
per code is all too common sadly users
arrive at the realization when it's too
late
the fact is some developers are good at
what they do
while others have poor coding skills a
team of software developers consists of
excellent good average and poor
developers
it is important that the bad codes
generated by many developers
need to be stopped else it may increase
the production time
devops helps in reducing the bad code
limits as the bad code cannot go to the
next phase until it is fixed
also a team member who is terrible at
coding
could be good at any other different
roles and vice versa
re-tasking team members earlier in the
process prevent wastage of time
and resources so in this way devops
eliminates bad developers and ensures
that the team comprises of good
developers
next at eighth position we have
increased efficiency
due to increment in efficiency level it
results in speeding up the process of
development
and also makes it error free devops can
also increase efficiency
through automation there are many ways
to automate tasks in devops
devops allows engineers to focus on
those tasks which are not automated
there are certain tools of acceleration
that increase the efficiency
they are the cloud-based platforms or
other scalable infrastructure
which help in increasing the access of
the team to the hardware resources
and hence speeds up the process of
testing and deployment operations
with the use of build acceleration tools
the code compiles faster
they may be a process that helps in
embedding parallel workflows
into the continuous delivery chain so
that the delays are avoided
moving on at seventh position we have a
better organizational
culture with the help of devops there
has been an
improvement in software development the
development and operation teams
are more focused on performing together
rather than having separate goals
the team is more focused on production
if both the teams are combined it will
result in innovative ideas in a very
efficient and effective manner there is
improved collaboration and communication
between the team members
devops facilitates better understanding
among the team members and this
understanding increases worker morale
next at the sixth position there is
faster release of software
it is true that devops makes the process
of software development agile
hence it leads to the timely release of
the software companies can quickly study
the behavior of users and
incorporate the changes to come up with
a better product this
in turn helps the organization to stay
competitive
there is a reduction in rollbacks and
failure rates regarding deployment and
the time that is taken to recover with
better products
devops reduces the time for cycles of
development
and also ensures a faster rate of
innovation at position 5
we have better knowledge of software
delivery lifecycle
once you get to know about devops you
will get a lot of information about the
software delivery lifecycle
it is divided into main phases like
planning analysis
design implementation testing and
integration and maintenance
in the plan phase initially there should
be a plan for the type of application
that needs to be developed
getting a rough picture of a development
process is always a good idea
in analysis a detailed study of
requirements is done
to check whether all the requirements
are available or not the list of all the
requirements like human
resources hardware software required to
accomplish this project successfully
will be clearly analyzed and listed out
here in the design phase
the whole project is divided into
modules each module into sub-modules by
drawing some diagrams using unified
modeling language
a pseudo code will be prepared at this
phase in the implementation phase
the application is coded as per the end
user requirements
coder now has the task to do the coding
developers will develop the actual
source code by using the sudo code
and following the coding standards the
testing and integration phase
is the most important step of the
application development here the
application
is tested and rebuilt if necessary the
multiple modules of codes from different
programmers
are finally integrated into one then
finally the application is developed and
delivered to the end users
the final phase is maintenance once the
client starts using the developed
software
then the real issues start coming up in
this stage the team
is required to fix the issues roll out
new features and
refine the functionalities as required
at the fourth position we have
boost product quality the concept of
devops does not allow mistakes in the
stage of methodology
when both the operation and development
stages are done correctly
with no errors then it will result in a
release of better
and improved product qualities this
leads to a cleaner
more efficient code and hence increases
the software quality with each release
the devops process brings better quality
to the development process and reduces
the chances of unplanned work
at the third position we have exposure
to trending technologies
and advanced tools devops works with a
variety of tools
few of them are nagios chef docker
git selenium puppet kubernetes ansible
and many more you will get a chance to
understand and use all these tools and
learn how to design
develop deploy and maintain an app or
software
with the help of these tools apart from
that by knowing all things about such
software and tools
you can increase your chances of getting
hired by the best companies
at the second position we have increase
your professional
credibility by obtaining a devops
certification
you can increase your professional
credibility this certification
will help you to let the others know
that you have sufficient skills in
monitoring a software's performance
easily write and code with scripts
enhancing the software security to a
greater extent
providing the best it hardware you will
be able to troubleshoot various issues
in the software
and finally you will be able to connect
software's databases and much more to
ensure effective functionality 42
of companies are now preferring open
source jobs and want candidates with
devops skills
so if you want to become a part of
developing the devops your market
then this is the perfect time to start
getting devops training
and finally the top reason to learn
devops is to get a perfect job and
increase your salary
devops is a very popular career choice
now researchers have also shown that in
the coming years devops will be the main
hiring criteria
for 46 of the it companies however they
are not
sufficient experts who can match the
requirements that's why
they are massive opportunities for
candidates seeking devops jobs
besides when it comes to salary you can
earn a lot of money
on an average a divorce professional
gets a pay of 99
604 dollars per annum in the united
states
and a divorce professional in india gets
an average salary of 6 lakhs
2 000 rupees per annum now
let me recap and call out all the 10
reasons for learning devops once again
at number 10 we had the technical
cultural and business benefits of devops
at number 9 we had work with good
developers at number eight
we had increased efficiency at number
seven we had a better
organizational culture at number six we
had faster release of software
then at fifth position we had better
knowledge of the software delivery
lifecycle at the fourth position
we had boost product quality and at
third position we had exposure to
trending technologies and advanced tools
at the second position we had increasing
professional credibility
and finally at the top position we had
get a perfect job and increase your
salary
now let me tell you how simply learn can
help you learn devops
so that you can start your career in it
so guys this is the official simply
learn website and i'm going to show you
the different types of devops courses
simply learn offers so first is devops
engineer
let's go ahead and look into that this
is a master's program
and it has seven plus real life projects
you can see the course curriculum here
that is git and github training
devops certification training devops on
aws
and more you can see the learning
objectives
the tools covered here are maven ansible
chef puppet solstack apache
city and many more you can see the
course curriculum
and you can see the electives that you
can choose
okay let's go back and look at another
certification
we had the devops certification training
so here you have 56 hours of blended
learning
over 10 industry projects with
integrated labs
24 hours of live demos and you have
flexibility to choose the classes
the skills covered are divorce
methodology
version control systems continuous
integration and deployment
tools and jenkins team city maven and
many more
so you can see the benefits here the
annual salary of a devops professional
the companies that are hiring devops
professionals
then we can see the course curriculum we
have introduction to devops
version control systems continuous
integration continuous deployment
then we have software and automation
testing frameworks we have
containerization with docker
and much more and you can see the
various tools that are
involved in this then we have our
industry projects
so guys in this way simply learn can
help you get a devops certification
so that brings us to the end of this
session we hope you found this
informative and helpful
if you've enjoyed this video please like
and share it and don't forget to
subscribe to the simply learn channel
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simply long
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here